-This is a fantastic film.
-Thank you.
-You play --This is based on -
a, reporter actually wrote
a very famous profile
of Mr. Rogers.
-He did.
-And he's is a bit cynical
-Yes.
-And sort of discovers
a lot about Mr. Rogers
over the process.
-Yes.
-You grew up in Wales.
Did you have any context
for Mr. Rogers?
-No. So, ironically,
I'm very cynical
and I knew nothing
about Mr. Rogers.
It was perfect casting.
-So you got to
take the same journey.
-Yes. I did very little.
-What was it like,
the first time?
'Cause, I imagine
it must be very jarring
when you're told
about Mr. Rogers
and you go back
and watch Mr. Rogers.
What was your first reaction
-Well, my first reaction,
I read the script and said
to Keri, "Who is Mr. Rogers?
She's, like "Get out. Get out.
[ Laughter ]
And she pointed up.
Mr. Rogers's voice, as it will
is already in our living roo
'cause our 2 1/2-year-old
was watching
"Daniel Tiger's Neighborhood."
So, I was, like,
"Oh, right, yeah."
So, then I took a deep div
and I thought something's wrong,
because this gentleman
is speaking very slowly
and it seemingly
only had one camera
that they would never cut away
and was he forgetting his line
and then I realized
it wasn't for me.
It was for children
of a certain age.
Then, I discovered
the true genius of "Mr. Rogers."
-Yes, absolutely.
They do say,
if you get introduced
to Mr. Rogers,
it's better if it happens
when you're young.
-Yes, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not, like "The Sopranos,
where they're like,
"Oh, you got to rewatch it."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"Start from the beginning."
-"Can't come in the middle
on 'Mr. Rogers.'"
-No, no.
What were your --
What was kids' television like
for you, growing up?
-A little strange.
-Yeah.
-You know,
my first language is Welsh
So, at that time,
when I was growing up,
the Welsh-language station
was a fledgling,
was discovering, you know,
its identity.
It wasn't quite sure
what children's television
should be or wanted to be.
A lot of strange puppets.
There were two gentlemen
who kind of would put a jacket
over the camera
and then beat each other up.
-Okay.
-It was -- It was strange.
So I went into acting.
-It's very strange
to do children's televisio
where part of it is
they hide themselves
from the children.
-And then -- Yes.
And then beat each other up.
-Yeah.
-So, that's what we did,
as children in Wales.
-Did your --
Is your 3-year-old --
Now, you said
he was watching "Daniel Tiger.
Did you start watching "Mr
Rogers" with him, as well?
-Sadly, or not, I think
he'll be richer for it,
but he kind of became
my Mr. Rogers guinea pig.
So, then I went and
put him in front of the show -
the actual show --
back, you know,
the black-and-white version, and
it was an incredible moment.
-He went for it?
-Oh, he still is.
It's, like, his daily
30-minute meditation.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
It is really meditative.
I mean, that's the great thing
about Mr. Rogers.
-And also as a parent,
I learned far more
from those 30 minutes...
Like, I'm the one
behind him, going...
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-So we're both learning.
-Good.
'Cause, I remember you wer
terrible at putting on a sweater
last time I saw you,
and now from watching
"Mr. Rogers," you just get i
on and off, like, right away
-Oh, like nobody's business.
Yeah.
I was -- Listen,
as well you know,
I was no stranger
to a wool knit sweater.
Six years, I served my time.
-That's right.
You -- Tom Hanks obviously
plays Mr. Rogers.
And you know, one of the thing
we all know about Mr. Rogers i
one of the things
we all know about Tom Hanks,
which is he's actually
as lovely as he seems.
It's kind of crazy, though
right?
-Yes, I'm almost to the poin
of going,
"When do I start a new rumor
just saying
that I'm gonna take down Hanks?"
-Yeah.
Just, like full-time bad guy
-I'll do both.
I'll take down Rogers and Hanks.
I'll go, "Listen,
I've discovered
two things about them.
You're not gonna like it.
Listen to me, America."
-Yeah, "They both have
a very dirty, dark secret
that is the same thing,
and it's awful."
-Yes.
It's to do with a cardigan
-Do you get...
[ Laughter ]
The first time you do a scen
with somebody like Tom Hanks
do you feel like, does it
make it harder as an actor
because you are aware,
obviously, as a person,
that it's Tom Hanks.
-Well, listen, for me,
not knowing Mr. Rogers, To
Hanks was my Mr. Rogers.
I grew up with Tom Hanks.
So it took me days
of trying to act
as if I wasn't nervous
or perversely star-struck
before I could start
acting with Tom Hanks.
-Yeah.
-So, I was acting,
trying to be calm and trying
to stop my head from sweatin
in front of Tom Hanks
before I could do anything
to do with the film.
So, it was one of the greate
acting jobs,
I think, I've ever done.
-Well, we all tip our caps
-Ah, yes.
-So, you had done this before.
So, Keri, your costar and
partner now in real life,
so, your first two years
in "The Americans,"
I have heard it told
that you were doing
the same thing with her.
You were not acting
to be in the scene.
You were just trying
to, like, impress her.
-The very same thing.
So, I spent the first two year
on "The Americans"
trying to impress Keri.
So I'm quite sure
my acting was at its worst
[ Laughter ]
And the same with Tom Hanks.
I wasn't acting
to serve the script.
I was trying
to impress Tom Hanks.
So, I'm just in this cycle
of trying to impress peopl
and not really
serving the script.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the key, though.
As long as your --
As long as your shows
run enough seasons,
we eventually get to see
you, the actor.
-Eventually, if you
give me the real estate,
I'll get there.
[ Laughter ]
I just need a solid three years.
-I have not seen you
since "The Americans" ended --
a show, I've told you before
I love so much.
It must be wonderful
to have left a thing
in very, just a pristine endin
of a show
that I think is going to endur
for years.
Does it feel great?
-Incredible.
And you know,
we were all very well.
We'd had
this incredible five years
We were all very worried
as to how -- what would happen
And you know, in all fairnes
to the writers,
they ended it
beautifully and perfectly.
I don't think-- I don't feel
we wrung the towel dry.
We kind of left it
on the right note.
-It was great.
Keri and you --
you have a 3-year-old,
and this is very exciting
for a 3-year-old.
She's is going to be
in the new "Star Wars" film.
-Yes, as soon as he
grasps that concept.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Because all you have right no
to show him
is her outfit in the film.
-Yes.
-So, this has been released.
-That's been released.
Well, what actually happened is,
I don't even know
who the toymaker is,
but they very kindly sent
the bobblehead to our house.
-Sure, that's
a nice thing to do.
-Yes, so, obviously, it's
not very well-proportioned
The head is giant.
it's a bobblehead.
And he opened it with Keri
Keri tried to explain
what this bobblehead was.
And then she -- I came hom
and he ran up to me
with the bobblehead
and said, "Mom's inside."
[ Laughter ]
I went, "Good.
Keep her there."
[ Laughter ]
"It'll be our secret."
-There you go.
-"Don't let her out."
Every now and then,
Mom needs to be
in the bobblehead.
-Yes, yes.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
it's always such a pleasur
to see you.
Congrats on the film.
Matthew Rhys everybody.